mind your decisions i'm presh tallwalker
five congruent circles are placed with
their centers equally spaced
a line is drawn from the bottom of the
first circle to the top of the fifth
circle
the area underneath the line and
overlapping the circles is shown in
yellow
if the yellow region has an area equal
to 40 and the overlap of two circles has
an area equal to five what is the area
of a single circle equal to
i thank joe m for the suggestion
pause the video if you'd like to give
this problem a try and when you're ready
keep watching to learn how to solve this
problem
[Music]
there are many ways to solve the problem
and i will illustrate just one method
notice the yellow region is exactly
equal to half of the total area
if we take two of these yellow regions
we will get the total area of the shape
recalling the area of the yellow region
is equal to 40 the total area of the
shape will be equal to 2 times 40 which
is equal to 80.
this total area is also equal to 5 times
the area of a single circle
minus four times the area of the overlap
between two circles
recalling the overlapping region has an
area equal to five we can substitute in
we then can methodically solve this
equation for the area of a single circle
five times the area of a single circle
will be equal to one hundred so the area
of a single circle will be equal to
twenty and that's our answer
thanks for making us one of the best
channels on youtube
see you next episode of mind your
decisions where we solve the world's
problems one video at a time
[Music]
you